it is now time for the section of the
show known as the hashtagwars
[Music]
on this day in the year of our Lord 1781
astronomer William Herschel discovered
the seventh planet in our solar system
Uranus or Uranus if some people falsely
call it and before you start with your
childish giggling the word Uranus has
nothing to do with your immature jokes
about the human anatomy it's actually a
latinized version of verrano's the name
of the Greek god of the sky seen here
with his nutsack hanging out we're going
to handle this important astronomical
discovery in the most mature way
possible with tonight's hashtag but
science examples might be that's a wire
frame that makes it grown-up shut up
examples might be but danke DaVinci and
my anaconda don't want none unless
you've got buns in burners I'm going to
put 60 seconds on the clock and begin
Jim Morton she blinded me with her big
fat ass all right
course Ricky Oh bill not anal guy
so could be true we don't know clients
in Close Encounters of the Third Kind
Thank You Houston I have a boner
yes very good Tim anal string theory boy
Jim again
Galileo that's a big fat ass all right
Ricky Neil that ass Tyson point Jim back
that ass up to the future boys Wow Jim
again but Aldrin what we've really found
Jim Norton sweet spot that NASA though
yes boy very good Ricky periodic table
of smellman all right there we go yes
Camilla
they bought series hi very good